good morning everybody and welcome to
this cabinet to this meeting of mid
Suffolk District Council cabinet my are
first of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure my guns are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave please remember to
use the chat function only to indicate
that you wish to speak and not to post
comments or questions please note the
messages in the chat panel can be viewed
by people watching the live broadcast I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded I'd now like to ask
Claire to do the introductions Thank You
Claire Thank You chair in addition to
the cabinet members today we also have
councillor Keith Whelan councillor John
field councillor Rowland war boys also
attending is our chief executive officer
Vania and I'm monitoring officer Emily
you'll thank you thank you very much
item 1 apologies for absence so that we
if you can't say to indicate your
presence when I call your name please
counselor Jared Brewster present
councillor David Byrne
can't see David Byrn are you a mute
yourself oh I beg your pardon
present a councillor Judy Flatman
present
Jessica Fleming person councillor Peter
gourd present present councillor Harry
Richardson present and councillor John
Whitehead present thank you item 2 on
the agenda is to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare yes
item 3 mca / 19 / 62 his confirmation of
the meat of the minutes of the meeting
that we held on the 9th of June 2020 are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the Midnight's could I have a
proposer please Thank You councillor
flapman a seconder please I'm happy to
second minutes it's Peter Gould thank
you Thank You councillor Gore the
governance officer will now take a roll
call vote thank you thank you you could
please answer for against or outstay
when I call your name councillor
Brewster councillor you're on mute
I believe you're still on mute counselor
Brewster you're right no okay sorry
approve Thank You counselor ban for
counselor Flatman for counselor Fleming
counselor Fleming are you on mute as
well
councilor Fleming yes
approve I'm sorry I've been trying to
get myself off okay Thank You councillor
Gould
Oh councillor Morley for councillor
Richardson for and council a
white-haired for thank you that's
unanimous thank you
the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and they'll be signed off at
the next practicable opportunity item
four is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme thank you very
much
item five questions by councillors thank
you
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint order
and standards committee thank you very
much item seven the forthcoming
decisions list do members of the cabinet
have any comments no thank you very much
item eight so we're now moving on to MCA
/ 1963 and this is the general fund a
financial out turn for 2019 2020 and I
will now invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce the report thank
you madam chairman I'm pleased to
introduce report MC a 1963 on the
general fund financial out turn for 1920
which is set out in the update to our
cabinet papers each year we highlight
the difficulty in forecasting our
business rate income we have established
a business rate equalization reserve to
smooth out the effect of business rate
variances we take the annual variances
on our business rates either to or from
that reserve this year I set out in
recommendation 3.2 B we will be taking
611 thousand from the reserve which
still leaves a balance on that reserve
of two point three five million
each year whilst controlling our
expenditure additional income over and
above that budgeted has produced a
surplus this year planning fee income is
30% ahead of budget but using a
favorable variance of 395,000 almost as
large a variance comes from the SIL
administration five cent top up at three
hundred ninety five thousand in fact in
the area of the cabinet member for
planning overall we have seven hundred
thirty four thousand favorable variance
so thanks counselor burn as we do have
some unfavorable variances in other
areas slower than anticipated investment
into Cisco has resulted in income from
that area falling two hundred thousand
below that budgeted strategic properties
in our own district have also cost us
ninety eight thousand pounds more than
anticipated on the environment and
housing side we have seen adverse
variances on car park income due to
ticket machine problems and a hefty
shortfall in in net income from our
solar PV panels that's net income after
expenditure from these which is only
four to four percent to budgeted levels
for the reasons we have rehearsed many
times already corporate resources show
overall 263,000 favorable variance held
primarily by extra investment income now
the details for all these cabinet
assistant director areas are set out in
Appendix A the overall net effect is to
produce a surplus for the year of
294,000 which we proposed in
recommendation 3.2 B to transfer the
growth and efficiency fund we offer
postings from Carrie Florida expenditure
twenty to twenty twenty-one 164,000 as
set out in the table in paragraph five
point sixteen so for mission for those
is requested in recommendation three
point three now as well as revenue we
also report a general fund capital
expenditure starting from paragraph five
point 17 of the report we had a very
ambitious capital program in nineteen
twenty and members will not be surprised
to hear we didn't complete a lot of that
within the calendar year in
recommendation three
for we're requesting the authorisation
to carry forward eighteen point nine
five six million now just over three
percent is already committees the bulk
being for the Regal theater regeneration
and just under fifteen point eight
million relates to various items set out
in paragraph five point twenty two
you'll see in that table by far the
largest item is eight point four five
two million for Cisco 1 million eight
hundred and forty seven thousand for
Gateway fourteen and also long with a
presently completely unspent three
million allocated for the strategic
investment fund now so far I've made no
mention of Cove in nineteen its effects
on the year ending 31st of March twenty
twenty were very marginal and it's real
effects we felt in the year 2021 and
indeed beyond that now this
administration has been criticized in
the past for our high level of reserves
by financial cushion as I'd like to call
them but we go into the new uncertain
Kovach era with a high level of reserves
and I say thank goodness for that
however many years this
well-administered council has built up
substantial reserves despite only
leveling very modest below inflation
casteau tax increases each year and all
our reserves are set out in detail in
appendix d our great deal of work is
presently being undertaken to evaluate
the ongoing effects of Cove in nineteen
on both our income streams and
expenditure but at present a lot of this
still remains as rough guesstimation x'
i will be reporting on this in more
detail in the first quarter report for
2021 but i do feel confident that the
strength of our accumulated reserves
will enable us to weather this
unprecedented storm as always before
finishing my outer and introductions i
like to pay tribute to the hard work
undertaken by our finance team in
closing out the books for the year and
in producing such a comprehensive
analysis in this report I'd like I'd
like I'd like now to move the
recommendation set out in paragraph
three would ask for a seconder thank you
madam chairman Thank You councillor who
would like to second and
I would very much like to second the
report Thank You councillor Gault I'm
the second the report and its
recommendation the the report tells a
very positive story and one that would
be envied by many councils while the
effects of kovat and he started to
impact on the end of that 1920 we can be
thankful to attach the Whitehead and the
finance team that we have such a strong
at term position from which to face the
pressures and uncertainty of the current
and future years the fact that this
position has been achieved while
delivering low taxation on one hand and
high social value on the other is
remarkable while council Whitehead and
the finance team are central and play a
crucial enabling role the delivery of a
strong financial position while
achieving key social outcomes is a
testament to a strong officer team led
by an able administration which has a
clear purpose and particularly an
understanding about the need to invest
rather than simply to spend I'm pleased
that the rental income from Cisco
investments continues to make a
significant contribution to the
council's revenue position and it's
disappointing that we've not been able
to invest to the level assumed in the
budget I hope there's no
misunderstanding here and that the
variance arises from doing too little
rather than too much investing thank you
madam chair thank you very much
councillor Galt so now we're over to
questions questions from members does
anybody wish to raise their hand
No are any non cabinet members wish to
ask a question no thank you very much
I'll now open up the item for debate
sorry chair oh sorry sorry I believe
counselor field and counsel women well
I'm a both indicated they'd like to ask
a question okay counselor field
counselor field we can hear you can you
can sorry my microphone symbol just one
ton and whatever is uncus itself out yes
thank you I suppose a comment if I might
be allowed one at this time is just that
although the video streams are perfectly
okay there does seem to be an issue with
the access to the modern Java and to the
and to the team's control panel both of
which are really a problem really I was
debating whether I have a question or
statement obviously the the real
question I suppose here is forgetting
the sort of political grandstanding or
anything that one could do the the issue
I always have with this financial return
is that there are a number of variances
which you know will happen in any
business things happen like there once I
can bid 19 that you just don't expect or
you expect but don't know where they
aren't we're within the next hundred
years it's going to fall so there are
always unexpected and you always expect
variations from exact budgets unless you
fiddle the numbers and you wouldn't
wanted to be doing that but there are
always a number of items to my mind
which are fairly obvious things like
some of the adverse spend on i.t on
perhaps Sippy the the photovoltaic
panels things like the telephone bill
which always looks like things that have
just been forgotten at budgeting time
and while there's no way I can expect
you to be clairvoyant in the suit so
yeah every eventualities I'm always
concerned that we have this persistent
background
of quite substantial items that don't
seem to hit the budget you know whether
there are counterbalancing ones I don't
know so the real issue is how did we
manage to get to that position and it
happens year on year not just this year
and that's the question one microphone
is come on right okay yes as you say the
would expect both adverse and fable
variances and of course that's why
during the year we do our estimated out
turns after quarter one quarter two and
quarter three because we're continuously
monitoring that and as well as things
come through that only do they have
effect on the current year but they may
have an effect on future years there are
continuously using this to update our
intelligence on an information I think
the example you gave on PV panels is a
good one because some each year we seem
to sort of try and become a bit more
prudent on that and each view is still
being caught out but hopefully at this
stage now when we got down to 44 percent
of what can tissa pated there must come
a time when you know these problems are
sorted out I think never spend on i.t I
think if we didn't have another spend on
i.t some people might query our our
accounting because that seems to happen
everywhere in the world isn't it and
they yeah I think again we've talked in
the past about probably the telephone
bills and you know I guess that's driven
by the sort of technology as we brought
it in but you know do you feel that we a
we should expect some adverse spend and
be away we do try and take that into
account as much as we can as and when we
prepare a budget but sometimes these
things have a sort of some delay because
we do our budgeting around the end of
the calendar year and then we're looking
at the things like these out terms you
know a good six months later thank you
you know you come back in one
understands that
the very there are will be variances but
the the statement really is as we're
heading into the next year with the
colossal impact of Calvin we really need
to make sure we're as as sound as we can
be that we get adverse things as clear
as nearly right as we can
but that we don't have things that are
just carelessly missed if you don't like
them because it is going to be a
challenging year as you pointed out I
just can't argue it any in other words
you just said there are I agree thank
you thank you
councillor Willem thank you very much
um yeah the chat function isn't working
on my laptop for some reason and nor was
the raising of the hand so I had to
actually way physically waive I've got
two queries one is on table two on page
22 where there is a transfer to reserves
of 17 K and a transfer of 86 from
reserves in respect of the joint local
plan so I guess that overall this means
that there is a higher than anticipated
spend on the joint local plan so
assuming that is correct um outside of
the meeting could I be given the total
cost of the work so far in the joint
local plan and what was budgeted and how
much further spend is anticipated and
some comfort that that's all been fully
budgeted for please yes I'm the police
to give you that information outside the
meeting and I've actually got rather
naughtily I've actually got a copy of
the report printed out on paper so I
can't actually see when he mention page
22 can you give me a paragraph number or
appendix number it's it's um table table
1 and table 2 I know that there's some
seems to be something old about the page
number II
but it is on my version it is page 22
yeah it's between paragraphs 515 and 516
oh right yes it's not big it's no big
matter it's just I could not understand
why there was a I transfer to reserves
in respective Jewett local plan and a
transfer form deserves and respected
joint local plan
I suspect it's actually two different
items but where the Katherine Melissa or
Sharon who are on the call can can just
confirm that is there an officer
available to comment on that I mean I'm
I'm happy I'm happy today here outside
of the meeting if it's not absolutely
clear to officers now okay Thank You
counselors I'm happy to jump in here it
is two separate items so the 86,000 from
reserves has been used to support costs
on the local plan and we can get you a
detailed breakdown of that and the
seventeen thousand pound transfer to the
reserves are two grants one is for
brownfield sites just over two and a
half thousand and the remaining 15,000
is actually to do with the custom-build
grant thank you that's brilliant thank
you if I could have the other
information outside of the meeting that
would be brilliant okay Sharon thank you
my my other queries in respect of the
growth and efficiency fund I see that
this is on page 33 and this may be
something that councillor Brewster might
want to inform you about after the meaty
I'm concerned that shock front grants as
an under spend of around 95% on
shopfront grants so it makes me wonder
whether the
300 the 350 K is likely to be spent
I did I did mention this before I felt
we needed to do more publicity about
this and now it's difficult over over
the Kovach period but yeah I just wanted
to be sure that there isn't any apathy
on the part of businesses and that the
way the waiter if we go to spend this
money the way to get it spent is for
there to be more publicity um I also
guess that most of this would be
expenditure in our towns and
particularly in stone market and I would
like to see you know I would like to see
this money spent on on revitalizing our
shops in stone market and the other
thing is that this if there is a problem
that doesn't bode well for the vision a
stone market so I think we need to do
something to encourage buying whether
it's by and by councilors buying by
local councils or by and by by the
businesses I've got to turn that into a
question what are we doing to ensure
that there is buying well I mean my
understanding is that this shopfront
grant has now been expanded or who said
some of the criteria have been slackened
so to enable it better uptake on it but
if castle brew starts to add to that I'm
happy to hand over to him thank you
madam chair if I can come in yes indeed
the the shop front scheme we did a
really good promotional job through the
team and within town and within district
which didn't get a large take up for
some reason or other however since the
scheme has closed we we let it remain
open for a time until I think it was the
31st of March and a number of businesses
did come in and most of that money has
been spent but spent really in this
financial in the car
financial year the rest of the money the
150,000 which is for the the new scheme
is what's remaining of it and that will
be spent as a 50,000 each year for the
next three years and that scheme will
open I understand
probably latest summer because we want
to move away from the recovery period a
little bit it's not technically for
recovery although of course it will go
that way as well don't if that helps you
counselor well I'm sure if I if I might
yeah that that's good news but I think
we all members ought to have a note of
what's going on so that we're aware that
that money is being spent and also you
know if there's anything we can do to
encourage the the spending of the 50,000
that's going to be available from summer
onwards yep we can we can arrange that
certainly obviously that's was for
slightly different purposes although
some of it is still for frontage work
it's as much smaller grant going along
there's three small grants and one a
little bit bigger but we'll keep you in
touch with that well as that gets
launched um can I just clarify I think
some of that money is to assist access
into the into the property into the
businesses is that correct
yes I mean it's it's it serves the same
purpose basically but it is a smaller
grant thank you thank you very much
councillor war boys thank you it's not a
question on the detail report or on the
timing of the report we're looking now
at figures from the 31st of March sort
of three months or so later is there any
reason why councillors don't get the
figures at the same time as a senior
leadership team so that they have a
chance to scrutinize and prepare any
decisions being made as
result of those figures especially in
this present emergency and things are
moving quite quickly well my comment I'd
make I think is that you know during the
year we do have look at the out turns at
the end of each quarter which which
requires to sort of forecast routes the
end of the year to get our best
estimates you know each time what those
out turns will be I mean we need to
close the books out for a statutory
point of view by the 31st of May which
is a two two month deadline and I think
it has to understand the complications
we have where we have effectively two
councils but one working together
operation so there's quite a lot of work
I was on behind the scenes too just to
split that out and also there's a
separation between revenue and capital
and separation between the general fund
and the HRA I mean I think this time
well last year I think this report came
to cabinet in June and I'm guessing part
kovaydin part other things just had it
slip forward to do lie but if Katherine
wants to make any other additional
comment I'd welcome that Katherine are
you there yes I am thank you thank you
madam chair
yeah just to say as well there is also a
lead-in time for preparation of reports
that come come into cabinet so the
senior leadership does see that this see
the numbers first but that's not a long
lead in time before and then we
obviously have the deadlines to go to
briefing and also then for final
publication so there is a probably about
a good month lead-in time to getting
figures prepared and the reports ready
for for publication so it's not possible
to turn them around immediately after
after the end of the year and as counts
and the white head said yeah we have
been operating in exceptional
circumstances this year the finance team
have had an awful lot to do in response
to that the covert 19 emergency council
and Whitehead also mentioned the
normal deadline for the publication of
the accounts as the end of May but the
government has actually extended that
this year to allow councils more time
under under the current situation and
we've taken some advantage of that we're
still aiming to publish our accounts in
July and that needs to go hand in hand
with this outturn report that you're
receiving today hopefully that stands a
little bit more to the situation thank
you
sorry counselor wall boys do you want to
come back yeah yes please so normally
you'd expect the report four weeks after
the end of the quarter no really what I
was saying is there is a good month
lead-in time from when the numbers are
ready to go through the various
processes of briefings and then to the
the deadline for publication for cabinet
we do normally look at a good two-month
preparation time so usually the
quarterly reports and the year-end
report are actually in the third month
after the end of that that quarter or
the year end so that is the timetable
that we usually operate - thank you very
much thank you
if I can ask counselor war boys and
field to put your hands down
thank you we're now moving into debate
and as the hands up function seems to be
running particularly slowly I'm just
going to go through everybody in
alphabetical order and as it was at last
cabinet meeting there were various
comments about if we do it in the same
order every time that people who may
feel disenfranchised shall we say by
being last so I'm going to make an
arbitrary decision and we're going to
start in the middle of the list and
continue alphabetically so I'm going to
start with councilor gold have you got
anything you would like to
part of the debate not it not at this
stage madam madam chair I was happy to
make a statement and supportive counsel
white heads report it at the start I've
got nothing to add at the moment thank
you very much lovely Thank You
councillor Gord councillor Richardson
Thank You chair I've just got a few
brief comments first I think it's just
to echo what comes to Whitehead said in
thanking both welcome himself and the
finance team for putting together this
out turn report under what must be
extremely challenging circumstances
but I'm gonna sort of broad a more
strategic point I would just like to
kind of reinforce the point that I think
has already be mentioned and that we are
in a very fortunate position to have
such a strong financial reserve that we
can draw down upon I know that council
why I had referred to it as this
financial cushion but I think we another
way of looking at it is as I sort of
rainy day fund and I think what with
what we're currently experiencing
something of a thunderstorm so I think
it's an enormous relief that we have
that that sort of fall back so that
obviously I know the picture will still
become clear over the next few months as
to exactly what consequences this
current crisis will have but I think we
we start in a very strong position and I
think it's important that we recognize
that and that we we keep monitoring this
as we go forward and that that's all I
wanted to say I think Thank You Council
Richardson councillor whitehead anything
else to it having spoken for five
minutes at the start I think I'll keep
stunned thank you very much
councillor Brewster thank you madam
chair
yeah I repeat what what the other things
have just been said because they really
say it all and it doesn't need repeating
but what I would like to say is that a
really big thank you to our finance team
not just for managing this report but
for all the work they've been doing over
the Cova period because there's this
true
and as pressure on them at times and and
I really appreciate what they've done
thank you Thank You councillor Brewster
councillor burn No thank you madam
chairman no comments at the moment thank
you thank you very much councillor
Flatman Thank You chair I just like to
reiterate what everybody else has said
and thank you to the finance team who
have done a sterling job as always thank
you very much and councillor Fleming
thank you I have nothing to add I just
thought absolutely agree with the
comments of councillor Brewster and
councillor Richardson very glad we've
got a reserves there to draw on and as
you rightly say it's a rainy day so we
will inevitably draw on it
thank you very much I'd also just like
to add that the comments around
overspend on some of our IT facilities
and functionalities without that we
would probably not be having this
meeting because our our customer call
center was recently upgraded and the
consequences of that are that every one
of our call centre members can work can
take calls from home without that we may
have been in a lot worse situation and
the fact that almost every one of our
meetings has gone ahead as scheduled
using things like teams and all the all
the IT facilities that we have available
are supported by our County colleagues I
think is a fantastic achievement because
it's not just 550 offices and over 80
counselors across both of our districts
it's it's just a fantastic achievement
the whole of the Suffolk system there's
five hundred people all dialing into our
our IT system
at endeavor house and I think a great
deal of thanks is due to our financial
team and also our IT team for enabling
us to to work the way we do so I'm now
going to ask the governance officer to
conduct a roll call vote Claire over to
you when I call your names if you could
respond with four against councillor
Brewster counselor Byrne excellent thank
you very much indeed so we're now gonna
move on to item 9 which is MCA / 19 / 64
and this is the housing revenue account
financial out turn for 1920
sorry 2019 / 2020 and again I'm going to
ask the cabinet member for finance to
introduce the report thank you madam
chairman and god it's not just me that
stumbles over some of these 1920 2020
ones etc right I'm pleased to now
introduce the second out turn report of
the day which is MCA 1964 which covers
the out turn for 1920 of our ring-fenced
housing revenue account this account
covers the council housing stock which
is presently 3299 homes along with
associated garages and land holdings in
the year under review we had budgeted in
linear deficit of 419 thousand as we are
still working under the centrally
imposed burden or the 1% per annum rent
reductions over the four-year period
1617 to 1920 so I suspect all of the
members will have been surprised as I
was initially now his first advise that
we were bringing in an HRA surplus this
year of 1.3 96 million
so I think the first question I need to
answer is what is the driver behind this
turnaround well we were budgeting in
nineteen twenty four two point eight to
seven million of capital expenditure to
come from our revenue budget and that's
not and told unusual indeed it's quite
normal however we have had slippage on
our HR a capital program that's set out
in the capital section of the report
starting at paragraphs five point eight
and with the table in 5.10 giving the
numbers our offices anticipates the
capital program of twelve point nine
million but only just
jute we'll just short a four point five
million has actually been spent in the
year we do have ongoing capital
commitments of just under seven point
five million to be spent in this current
year 2021
well these along with other plans and
aspirations for capital end in the
investment as detailed in paragraph five
thirteen total eight point three one
nine million and the recommendation
three point three seeks cabinet's
authority for these capital carry
forward requests turning now to the
other outcome variances these are set
out in the table in section five point
five and the explanatory narrative is in
paragraph five point six sections a
through two G our members need to note
some changes to the bold headers in
sections five point six a and sections
five point six B housing management
should read as an adverse variance of
six hundred eighty three thousand
another four hundred seventy five
thousand the difference is accounted for
by corporate recharges and write-offs
all the remaining narrative in this
section is correct responsive repairs
and maintenance should read as an
adverse variance of five hundred and
forty four thousand and not five hundred
and fifty three thousand that's just a
minor change and the narrative again is
correct
now these major adverse variances
against budget highlight the many
operational challenges facing the HRA
but I am confident madam chairman that
the HRA management recognized these
challenges and that robust action plans
are well underway to address these
issues well when we come to question
debate the Assistant Director for
housing as well as the cow remember for
housing are here to provide further
detail and assurance to members so I
think that covers all I want to say from
a financial perspective the capital
program in earmark reserves are set out
in Appendix A and B I'd like to move the
three recommendations set out in Section
three and I'd like to invite the cabinet
member for housing to second those
recommendations thank you Thank You
chair Thank You councillor whiteheads
yes I'm very happy to second the
proposal thank you
Thank You councillor flapman do we have
any questions
oh I'll go through a roll call I think
as the hands up functions still a bit
flaky don't have any questions from
counselor Brewster I have none madam
chair Thank You councillor Bern no thank
you
councillor Fleming
no questions councillor Gord no
questions councillor Richardson is
really Thank You chair Thank You counsel
oh we don't need to ask council
Whitehead do I so do we have any
questions from any other members who are
present right it's a bit difficult I
just can't get access to modern golf
despite having Farber to the premises
here and in 50 megabits bandwidth the
questions I really had about those two
major variances that John White had
mentioned the Torah theme which amount
to about a million pounds in total to
turn around it's again the two issues
which it's quite difficult to see just
why they are so large
bear in mind and we're supposed to have
budgets that to deliver what we say will
deliver at the cost we say we'll deliver
it so real question is or you said
you're confident that those issues are
now under control and how do you really
justify that confidence is it I think
the main confidence is because as the
cabinet we get briefings on increasing
what seems to be an increasingly regular
basis and among those briefings are
various things to do the HRA the MBS etc
and in all those meetings over the last
few months where the housing assistant
director has come in and spoke to us and
he not only himself but also several of
your staff they just give me that
confidence level that they see where
things have been going wrong in the past
to see where they need changing and as I
said I'm confident that they have robust
plans in place to to do this turn around
thank you I'd like to invite Gavin to
elaborate on that thank you cabinet of
thank you chair Thank You councillor
field for the question I think if I can
just provide some detail as if I could
just take take a few minutes of your
time I think we recognize that Building
Services has presented its challenges
over recent years we will call similar
conversations for each of the last three
years I think it's important to note
that if you look on year-on-year in each
of our three years the overall deficit
for building services has and is
reducing and and thus an improving
picture one of the challenges that we've
had within building services is the
backlog or the generation of outstanding
job tickets and that's been up to as
many as 7,000 job tickets since dating
back as far as 2017 but I'm pleased to
say that since January we've actually
been our successful and closed more than
6,000 of those job tickets and now we
have in real terms normal levels of work
in progress in relation to building
services some of the most significant
overspend is as a result of the use of
external contractors and if I can just
summarize some of the steps that have
been taken or are being taken to manage
that effect in order to provide counsel
of fearwood and counselors with some
reassurance so if I take you back just
to the heady days before kovat and we go
back a year to to April 19 you'll
remember that we were talking in detail
about the reduction in void x and hence
decisions were made more than a year ago
to employ contractors to carry our help
major works and support the void times
that successfully brought forward times
down to a level but well below target
which is now averaging about 14 to 15
days and is below the target of 21 if we
then jump forward again to 2 now over
the last three months obviously we've
all faced lockdown and we've all faced
working from home that building services
team practically obviously can't do that
for obvious reasons and I'm pleased to
say that during the lockdown period it
actually has brought forward more than
60 empty properties and returned those
without the support of subcontractors
and that's not just for that period I
think that the trend has been a gradual
reduction in the use of subcontractors
for major spend so I really want to
celebrate and and promote that
achievement in addition to that we have
been looking at the spend of
subcontractors and we have identified
specialist roles where we see a high
level of reliance on those contractors
obviously examples for me would be
around windows and doors and we've
therefore developed a robust training
schedule for all staff in the service
which identify some of those specialist
roles and will provide them with
investment in training in order to
reduce our reliance in addition to that
we have identified some contracts some
subcontractors where we are you
them for large amounts of reactive work
when I talk about reactive work I'd
describe for example fencing works and
we saw in in January this year
significant amount of work as a result
of of a storm at that point as such
we're now developing capital programs
where a significant amount of that
activity can be let through attended
contract and then in the latter half of
last year in the beginning of this year
we have been reviewing all of our
contracts and identifying savings where
appropriate some of those conversations
still go on with some of the most
sizable contracts such as our whole
house servicing contract but we have
also positively taken steps to reduce
our overall material spend as a result
of conversations with our material
suppliers so I hope that provides some
reassurance to to members of some of the
action that is being taken to reduce the
the level of variances in building
services and I will be attending a
cabinet briefing on Monday next week to
provide the cabinet with further detail
as to the effects of improvement plans
in building services the level of
achievement over the last 12 months and
our plans going forward with respect to
investment and delivering even greater
indicators and achievements thank you
very much for that very fulsome answer
yes possibly follow that counselor field
I could try I hope next year's budget is
realistic but Congress might have some
things to say about that yes it's just
we're managing things that go on for a
long time and building work the one
understands he's not simple but people
have been doing it for hundreds of years
and we really need to get a grasp but it
sounds as though Gavin's doing that so
ok oh-o-oh
hope that I don't have the leg to stand
on body under next year thank you
so I'm now going to open up the item for
debate and again I think we'll go
through in alphabetical order just to
to stir it up in in fact I'm going to go
in reverse order just to keep you all on
your toes
so counselor Richardson would you like
to say anything
no major comments for me just to say big
thank you to Gavin and his team for his
hard work and hope that it continued to
improve over the next few months
thank you very much counselor Gould
thank you okay just to echo canceller
Richardson's comments and and thanks to
tutor Gavin and his team there's a real
sense I think that things are improving
the city is great that things are
improving in that I share the confidence
that others have expressed thank you
madam chair thank you very much
councillor Fleming I agree no further
comments to add thank you Thank You
councillor flapman I'll thank you chair
well I'm just gonna say that the housing
team have been absolutely brilliant
throughout this coffered 19 we've had
homelessness to deal with we've had the
the the maintenance team going into all
these voids and getting them back into
surplus you know it is it's just been
incredible and obviously Gavin heads up
the whole suffolk team as well which
just shows that mid Suffolk are at the
forefront
you know we we're not just standing back
and letting County and others organize
it our team has been at the forefront of
trying to get a joined up service in
place so that when we do have problems
with residents and and housing that it's
a joined-up approach with the health
team and absolutely everybody to give
these people the help they need to be
housed and and get work thank you Gavin
and all the team thank you very much
council equipment like Elsa Bern
thank you madam chairman and come to the
flatlands confidence and enthusiasm is
is in infectious and
I too am very pleased with the way
things are going in the housing team so
hats off to Gavin and his crew and
thanks to Julie for steering it from our
side of the fence thank you thank you
very much councillor Brewster thank you
madam chair yeah yeah I mean the the
building services team have had quite a
difficult time of it in terms of what's
gone wrong and what now hopefully is
going very right and I suspect that some
of that problem really came from trying
to offer him in fact joining the two
district council teams and these sort of
joined up things can bring their own
difficulties and it takes time to work
through I really had to admire Gavin for
the work he's done because he hasn't had
an easy time over that period and I
think we will be going into a period
where where things become easier as we
move forward so thanks Gavin and please
thanks to to thank the team for us for
what what they're doing as well because
it does take a team to to resolve some
of these sort of issues thank you thank
you very much so Gavin please take back
the entire cabinets thanks for
everything you're doing on the housing
oh we have seen a marked improvement
over the last the last year and thank
you very much from all of us to all your
team thank you I will now ask the
governance officer to conduct a roll
call vote Thank You Claire councillor
Brewster for Oh
councillor Gord poor councillor Morley
for councillor Richardson for councillor
Whitehead for thank you thank you very
much now we're going to move on to item
10 which is MCA slash 1965 and this is
the adoption of the revised table
affairs for Hackney carriages so I'm
going to invite the cabinet member for
the environment to introduce this report
cancel Fleming thank you thank you very
much chairman and cabinet members some
it is my pleasure to introduce the
revised table affairs for Hackney
carriages in mid Suffolk today and I
hope that everyone can even concur with
the proposal to adopt the revised fares
in Appendix II before I come to the
details of the actual report before you
I just like to draw your attention to a
couple of minor Corrections section five
the report begins at page 50
incidentally report but if you look at
section 5 links to joint strategic plan
this should be replaced by links to
corporate plan and section 8 risk
management the risk register has been
updated since the report came to the
licensing and regulatory committee the
reverend relevant operational risks are
to a o 3 regulating to supporting
business growth and to a or for relating
to business survival not to a o 1 as
stated so I just wanted to draw your
attention to those items in addition you
will know that you will have received a
set of appendices attached to an email
this morning and they are not
fundamentally different from the
appendices in our report that they are
named clearly and independently of one
another so that just clear which
appendix beginning and ends
well sew them those will be the real
indices that I refer to today um me
setting tariffs for Hackney carriages
the aim is to achieve a reasonable
balance between the taxi operator and
the traveling public the taxi operators
have obviously got expenses in
purchasing maintaining and running their
vehicles while ensuring that travel is
affordable for the public and it's and
is safe and supports a vibrant local
economy now turning to the mid Suffolk
Territory review fares for Hackney
carriages in mid Suffolk as as it stated
in your report had not been increased
since 2011 which is way overdue I mean
the statutory public notice was issued
in the local press on the 5th of March
2020 and a notice was posted at the
council offices to the effect that the
fares were to be reviewed access points
within two districts also advertised the
proposed variation of hackney carriage
fares as required by the Local
Government Act 1976 in response to the
consultation only one response was
received from the hackney carriage trade
which objected to the proposed revision
of fares that we had put out for
consultation this response is in your
packet as Appendix C the appear officers
comments are at appendix D there was no
there were no responses to the table
Affairs from the general public at all
during the consultation period now this
may have been due to the effect of the
kovat pandemic because we were just
going into lockdown at the time so I
suppose in a sense the there may have
been more responses had just been at a
normal time however we did receive
informal
feedback from taxi operators
particularly in snow market who wanted
to see the fares increased a bit more
than that which was which were proposed
and particularly the night fares the
single consultation response was
considered by our officers and a result
of this representation an alternative
proposal was put forward the
consideration by the Licensing and
regulatory committee with the aim of
achieving a slightly larger pay increase
for the trade this was welcomed by the
committee who were concerned that there
had not been an increased for so many
years and this need needed to be
addressed
therefore the report before you today is
recommending the adoption of the revised
table of fares
not exactly those that were put out for
consultation which appear in Appendix II
of our reports they in the licensing
committee formally made the following
recommendations to adopt to consider
adopting the revised table Affairs
modified under option 2 appendix E for
Hackney carriages within the control
zone of the mid south of district
council and once adopted the revised
table Affairs should become effective on
the 27th of July 2020 so when you first
look at Appendix A in Appendix II you'll
notice at least I thought at first they
were identical they actually aren't
because the yardage in which the fares
differentials kick in differ in favor of
the hackney carriage operators even
though the actual amounts that you first
look at are the same I would also like
to advise you that the hackney carriage
in private hire vehicles sees for Baber
and mid Suffolk are currently under
review and will come before the
licensing and regulatory committee in
October this year the intention is that
the new joint policy will require an
all-new annual review of hackney
carriage tariffs to ensure that they
remain in line with the Consumer Price
Index in the future
although there will be a joint policy
for Babel and mid Suffolk the tariff
tables are different now and are likely
to be completely harmonized harmonized
in the near future
due to the nature of the districts and
the most common journey types for
example in Baber most taxi journeys are
short around Sudbury and the tariff
table needs to allow the drivers to take
in sufficient income from these short
journeys then would be appropriate in
the more rural areas of mid Suffolk and
you will see that we have in mid Suffolk
an optional 5-pound additional fare
which may be added at the discretion of
the driver and I think the most almost
all cases will be added and this
compensates a taxi carriage driver for
the expense of going out to a rural area
to pick someone up because they can only
actually charge from A to B not a from A
to B to C so on you know having said
that and I assume everyone has had a
good look at the report I would like to
put it back to you with the
recommendation to adopt the fare
increases in line with Appendix II of
our reporter I think you can't sleep
lemming do we have a seconder do I have
a seconder you're muted yes sorry I was
muted and yes chair and councillor
Fleming very happy as I sit on licensing
board to second that proposal Thank You
councillor Flatman so do we have any
questions from members start with
councillor Brewster thank you madam
chair
yeah as also a member of the licensing
committee I really do have no questions
on this okay thank you very much
councillor Byrne no thank you madam
chairman of no questions
councillor Gord no questions for me
my name is yeah counselor Richardson and
their questions for me Thank You chair
counselor whitehead and their questions
excellent thank you I can see that
counselor Williams got his hand up
counselor Willam Thank You chair and
castle affirming made reference to the
joint taxi policy which is about to be
drafted or work will commence on it in
doing that will consideration be given
to the steps which could be taken to
incentivize the use of the electric
vehicles please I think that that may
come out as a recommendation from the
work of the task group but I think it's
probably premature now but I've let
Cassandra Clements comment on that
Cassandra would you like to comment
good afternoon company thank you very
much for the question and I absolutely
agree that the policy review that's
coming back to cabinet in October is
exactly the right place to take a look
at that kind of recommendation I know
there are some councils that are looking
at potentially reducing license fees for
electric vehicles such as South
Cambridgeshire and that particular
example has a rather large
infrastructure to sort it so I know that
their County Council has received
central government funding to get an
exclusive evie charging point for all of
their taxis and they have a very robust
policy that is currently out to
consultation talking about all taxis
moving to being electric within the next
eight years so it there that particular
example is possibly one of the extreme
examples but absolutely I think our
licensing committee could look at
potentially looking at an licence fee
charges as part of the policy review
this year thank you very much
does anybody else have any questions so
I'm moving to open up the item for
debate councillor Brewster
I strongly recommend this this updated
policy madam chair I think it's it
brings this sort of return that the
drivers do need from my experience of
still market it can be very very
difficult to find a taxi in the evening
on questioning about this it was
explained to me that in fact it is
difficult for firms to to obtain drivers
in the evening simply because the return
was not great enough so I think you know
this this will support that and
hopefully provide more taxis running
certainly all day and into the evening
time Thank You councillor Brewster
councillor burn No thank you madam
chairman I know coming Thank You
councillor flapman just to reiterate
chair that yes this was debated fully on
the licensing board and across party
representatives all decided that we
should go with this
this amendment thankfully Thank You
councillor flapman councillor gaunt
nothing to add thank you thank you
Thank You councillor Richardson the only
comment I would make chair is just to
say that I am fully supportive of the
licensing committee's recommendations
I'm very pleased to see that there was
cross-party support for that I think
this is a very sensible approach I think
particularly given the fact that I'm
sure many acne carriage drivers will
have had particular difficulties over
the last few months I think this is
exactly the right time to be considering
this so I welcome it wholeheartedly
thank you very much
councillor whitehead um I do find the
Appendix II particularly the yardage
tariff quite bizarre I mean I can
calculate now that I can do 2,000 119
yards we charge for pound sixty and an
extra yard beyond that would cost me
another 20 pence all providing the taxi
does
twelve minutes three seconds but I said
it I just find that he'll have a bit
bizarre there from the sort of mileage
of yardage point of view but I guess
must be some logic behind it that I
can't see so I'll support it lovely
thank you very much and so I'm now going
to ask the governance officer to conduct
the roll call vote Claire thank you
councillor Brewster for for for Fleming
for not so good oh that's Lamoni for
Richardson oh that's the Whitehead for
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much indeed
so um that's the end of all the items on
the agenda
um and don't closing the meeting at
12:41 thank you everybody for your
attendance
well Marty thank you very much
[Music]